february is american heart month a time
when people can focus on their health
and intermountain healthcare heart
services the sponsors of this segment is
working to educate people about ways to
enhance their health and joining me to
tell us more is dr pamela ivey
cardiologist with intermountain
healthcare thank you so much for joining
us today you're welcome mercedes let's
talk about heart health and heart
disease how prevalent is it in the
united states it's still the number one
reason why
people die in this country you know
every minute
somebody dies of a heart attack
it's a message that i think still
the public should really hear
why do you think the rates are so high
well i think that
even now in this time of covid
we're still seeing risk factors for
heart disease that are
not being treated you know smoking is
still very prevalent even in our teenage
population
we're seeing people unfortunately be
less physically active and nutrition
still is a is a problem for many people
they say that an ounce of prevention is
worth a pound of cure and there are ways
that you can really help minimize uh
the effects of heart disease what are
some of the things that people can do
today to help their future
so one of the
things that that every person should do
is know what their cholesterol is that's
a really good start
also know where your blood pressure is
and that usually means a visit to the
doctor once a year
to get those things measured and taken
care of particularly if you have a
family history of coronary disease
that's something you definitely want to
pay attention to i'm sure exercise is
one of the things how much exercise
should the average person be getting a
day that's a really good question the
american heart association says that we
all should be getting about 150 minutes
of exercise weekly okay that turns out
to about 30 minutes five days a week and
walking counts walking is exercise we
love walking that that i mean it's good
for your bones too it's good for
everything you mentioned smoking that
obviously is something that you can cut
out but let's talk about the everyday
stresses uh
what are ways that we can de-stress
so i think being with friends
not being alone
going out and exercising as we've
already talked about
taking time for yourself we're all in in
this very busy world and and uh working
hard but still having some scheduling
time to relax and and be with family is
always a good idea well thank you for
what you do
health care providers
you are our angels and thank you for the
great information thank you again to
intermountain healthcare for sponsoring
this segment for more information visit
intermountainhealthcare.org forward
slash nevada and we